- We are back and I'm hanging
with Justin Timberlake.
Give it up, everybody!
(audience cheers)
One of my favorite things about Justin
and seeing him live is that
he loves a horn section.
I do as well.
Instruments like the sax,
trumpet, and trombone
definitely breathe a
special energy into music.
Our next guest is a very
talented trumpeter who came -
I don't say "trumpeter"
enough, it's a weird word -
who came to a stark realization when he
was growing up.
He didn't know any female trumpeters.
Now he's working to change all of that
with his New Orleans-based nonprofit,
Girls Play Trumpets Too.
Please welcome Troy, everybody!
(audience cheers)
Meet Justin.
(audience claps)
So you said growing up,
you didn't see any females
playing trumpet, right?
- Right, so my first
instrument was a violin.
I played that for a couple years
and then I picked up the
trumpet in fourth grade,
so growing up in New Orleans, you know,
it's a brass city, drum city-
- Musical city.
- -but I didn't see-
it's a musical city,
the birthplace of jazz,
and so I didn't see
any professional female
trumpet players growing up,
so I felt like girls and women could not
play the trumpet on
the professional level.
- Absolutely.
Whenever I heard you say that earlier,
I was like, "I don't
know that I did, either,"
now that I'm thinking about it.
Even like I love a horn section on stage,
and I don't know that I noticed-
you have brass, always
involved in every show you do.
- Yes, the energy just gets lifted
with brass accompanying.
- [Kelly] It's sexier.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I like a trumpet.
Well, you have a theory, though,
of why few women play, right?
- Well, yes, because the
trumpet's a lead instrument
and it represents leadership,
and so for a long time,
especially band directors
would discourage girls from
playing that lead instrument
'cause they felt like
they were not leaders
and they were not strong enough,
so they would put them
on a woman instrument
like a flute.
"You go play that flute!
You're not strong enough
to play that trumpet."
And so growing up in New
Orleans, like I said,
I didn't see any professional
female trumpet players
until I saw one that came-
she came from Canada to New Orleans
and performed at Dillard University
and she was playing a lot
of Miles Davis's tunes.
And Miles Davis is one of
my favorite trumpet players,
besides Louis Armstrong, you know?
And so I was like, "Wow, she can play!"
So that knocked down the walls of
gender bias within me and then traveling
around the world seeing professional
female trumpet players that I actually
became their best friend, you know,
like, okay, yeah.
- Yeah, it's inspiring.
So, who would you say your-
I think my favorite female musician
would probably be Sheila E.
I just love working with
her and I love her so much
and I love percussion 'cause
I can't keep time like that.
But who's one of your
favorite female musicians?
- Oh gosh, so many.
Nina Simone.
- [Kelly] Oh, yeah.
- That's my favorite, too.
(crosstalk)
- Yeah, I mean, Etta.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Because for me, you
know, I think sometimes
somebody like Whitney
or Etta would say, like,
"Oh, they're your favorite singers,"
but they were musicians, you know,
to the full extent.
And, I mean, there's so many-
I could keep going on and on,
but we only have so much show.
- [Kelly] No, Aretha, as well, yeah.
- Aretha, I was about to say-
(crosstalk)
- Everybody knows the
singer, but great pianist.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
How did you start Girls Play Trumpets Too,
like where did that kind of start?
- So, you know the devastation of
how Hurricane Katrina
devastated New Orleans.
And, you know, traveling around the world
and being away from home and seeing all my
fellow just New Orleanians
being devastated
by that storm.
And I got away, you know, I evacuated.
So I felt like it was my responsibility
to come back and go back to New Orleans
to help rebuild New Orleans, yeah,
and then I got inspired
to join this organization
that would get professional
musicians that have degrees
to teach at a school
that didn't have enough
money in their budget
to pay for a full-time
music teacher, and that
organization's called
Artist Corps New Orleans,
so it got me into actually teaching music
in the school system and I'm the only
black male teacher there, so I feel like
they were looking at me and I feel like
they needed me and I needed them.
And I said, "You know
what, imma keep it going."
And I decided to put a after
school program together,
specifically focusing on the trumpet,
teaching everyone how to play the trumpet,
but my best trumpet player was a girl.
- Yeah.
- And she said, "Do you
know who Valaida Snow is?"
I said, "No, I don't."
She's like, "You don't
know who Valaida Snow is?
What's wrong with you?"
- So disappointed in you.
- She was, she was.
So Valaida Snow was a black woman
that played the trumpet that traveled
all over the world in 1920s,
and so she's our inspirational model
for Girls Play Trumpets Too.
I was scared at first of like,
"I don't know if I can do this program,"
but my lady encouraged me to do it.
She said, "That's it."
And I was trying to come
up with different names
for the program.
She's like, "No, Girls Play Trumpets Too,
T-O-O, that's it.
Keep it simple."
Yes, so.
- It's very memorable.
She's got good ideas.
- Every time I trumpet, I win.
There you go!
(audience cheers)
Nice callback!
(upbeat jazz music plays)
(audience cheers)
What's up, everybody?
I'm back with Justin Timberlake and Troy!
Troy is the founder of
Girls Play Trumpets Too
in New Orleans and you
just saw a couple of
his students showing off their skills,
so Troy's nonprofit offers
girls more than music lessons.
It's also creating a sisterhood,
which is very important.
Joining us now are two of his students,
9-year-old Bailey and
11-year-old Crissana.
Give it up!
(crowd cheers)
Welcome to the show, ladies.
Meet Justin, I know you know Troy.
(Bailey giggles)
So I have to ask.
So you were amongst the
first to join, right?
So what was it like?
What was the first experience?
- Well, when I joined
Girls Play Trumpets Too,
I was very nervous because I couldn't even
play not one note, like at all.
- [Kelly] Yeah, you gotta start somewhere.
- I couldn't even hold the trumpet.
But now I can actually play all the notes.
- Okay, nicely done.
What about you, Bailey?
- It was okay because, you know,
it was like really
inspiring because, you know,
you get a little nervous sometimes,
but at the same time, you know,
like Crissana said, we could
not play a note at all.
(audience and Justin laugh)
- Those are when the parents are like,
"Mhm, just keep going."
(Crissana laughs)
I played violin when
I was a kid, and well,
there's a reason why I still don't.
(Crissana laughs)
Yeah, so it was not good.
But what do you think you've
learned about yourselves?
'Cause it's also about connecting.
Like when I was in choir as a kid,
I loved also the friendships that I made
in the class, so it's
about that, as well, right?
- I learned that trumpet
actually brings out
a lot of joy in me.
- Yeah.
It's a joyous sound.
That's so beautiful and simple!
(audience claps)
I love that.
What about you, Bailey?
- It's the same thing like Crissana said.
It also brings out the
frequency, you know?
Like all the music in one whole bunch.
It really brings out so
much joy in everybody.
- You know what you just said?
I love that, like the feeling of it.
'Cause I remember I sat in
on a session in a studio
and it was like a string section, horns,
there's a whole orchestra was there,
and sitting in the room,
you feel like the vibrations,
the wind from the instrument.
It's a magical thing to feel.
I'm glad you brought that up.
And to be in tune with
that at such a young age
is so cool.
What do you see in these girls?
Like these qualities in these girls?
- So one thing about Crissana,
I've been teaching her
for a couple of years, and she will always
bring this joy and I called her Smiley,
and she's always smiling, see,
you look at her right now.
I called her Smiley, then when she
joined Girls Play Trumpets Too,
she said, "Oh, my stage name is CoCo,
call me CoCo."
So, welcome to the stage, CoCo, everyone!
- [Kelly] CoCo!
(audience cheers)
You got a stage name?
I like it.
- The one thing I can say about Bailey,
she's a deep thinker.
Her responses are deep,
and she will come early
to Girls Play Trumpets Too
before all the girls
come because she's like,
"I hope they don't come so
I can get a private lesson."
(audience laughs)
So that says a lot about her
and I call her the Serena Williams-
- [Kelly] That's a good work ethic.
- Yeah.
You gotta put that extra
time in and, you know,
she really wants to get some extra time
to get better.
- I love that.
It takes dedication to
get good at something,
so that's awesome.
Do you have any advice for the girls?
- I feel like I want advice from them.
(Kelly and Troy)
I remember being so young and being
so inspired by music and knowing that
it affected me in such a positive way,
so just to hear how you're
so tapped into like-
it really is a different
frequency, you know?
And also, too, the relationships
that you will make in your
life with other musicians
that share this same feeling will be
relationships that you will never forget.
They will become your extended family,
like I talked about
musicians that tour with me
and the musicians that I get to play with
in the studio and so many
friendships that are made
over this feeling that you share about
creating music together and I don't even
know what to say.
I'm so blown away by these two-
- It's a blessing to be a part of.
- -these two young old souls over here.
- Yeah.
So where do you see the
program going from here?
- So we wanna expand.
We're actually expanding
two schools for us,
creating partnerships with schools
to do after school programming
and so we're actually in
need of more trumpets,
more music stands, more method books,
and funds to actually pay the instructors
to teach at these different schools.
- Especially 'cause
they're taking music and
art programs out of schools, so like the
after school programs are so important.
- Right, so important.
And I wanna expand it to the world
to where we can actually
do it online, and so-
- Yeah, and reach everybody.
- Reach everyone.
Because girls and women
can play trumpet, too.
- Yeah.
Yeah, you can.
(audience cheers)
Well, there is a surprise that Justin has,
so I'll let you take over from here.
- In my hometown in
Memphis, I'm very hugely
involved with Stax Academy,
which is the music program
for, you know, young people in Memphis
and I remember being-
I think it was probably
third or fourth grade
and the music program
in our school got cut.
And it was heartbreaking for me,
but I heard about y'all's story and
I was just really so
touched by the whole thing
that I wanted to make a donation
to make sure every student
gets a new trumpet.
- Yeah, which those are pricey!
Those are expensive.
(audience cheers)
It's amazing.
(Troy mumbles indistinctly)